can I just say one last thing before we
go
if you're listening and you're on the
fence about this conversation or you're
just on the fence in general you you
need that one thing to push you over all
I'm saying to do is commit to one
positive thing every day and it's little
stuff little push-ups whether it's
Fitness whether it's nutrition whether
it's [ __ ] closing your eyes and
breathing for two minutes breathing's
big beautiful water
I think I've drank four glasses of water
in my life mistake this [ __ ] walks
around with a tub
look at that [ __ ] you drank the whole
[ __ ] no you do not drink the whole
[ __ ] thing I don't believe I drink I
drink one and a half of these a day but
I'm also an athlete so I I take one of
another level what athlete podcast
Nation I'm really excited about this uh
one of my favorite humans on the earth I
feel like it's the only business outside
of my businesses that I kind of like
try it's a funny thing to say but this
is a big shout out to all my like when I
invest in companies I'm like look
you're getting my money you don't get
garyvee like I'm just trying to be
honest with people now I don't have
really the bandwidth for advisory or of
course I'm in bat phone and I'm always
about that but
um the extremely handsome gentleman in
front of me right now uh is putting the
other business I have a lot of passion
for a lot of you know we did some fun
stuff I actually want to ask you about
that what we did with the Discord where
you basically came everyone's personal
trainer but why don't you tell everybody
who you are what you work on let's go
into a little bit of the War Stories I
also I'm excited about it because
I we I I wanted to actually potentially
do this podcast you know in December
January because I think people are
always like ready to get their [ __ ]
together health-wise but then I also
thought about how I said to myself I was
gonna get my [ __ ] together at 40 and I
got it together at 38 and a half and so
like why give away another three months
of this year for the listener on the
other side of this like eating better
working out eating cleaner eating you
know just thoughtfully is a good word
um I think is always a good idea and so
I think you're you're one of the kings
of that and so it's good to have you on
the show thanks for having me last time
last time I was on the show we talked a
lot about uh
[ __ ] house that I broke into yes the
garage sale stuff house is no longer no
longer there this one this one I want to
be very selfish for my audience to be
frank because now you're now you're in
it you have this direct to Consumer you
know uh superfood brand you
you one of the core reasons I wanted to
invest is the apparel and the uh oat
based meal
just even watching because I'm closer to
it like the trials and tribulations I've
had 78 plans for V friends for the last
year 36 great 20 not great six forgot
about four atrocious like you know I I
think it's super important to have real
entrepreneurs on the show and talk about
the trials tribulations when the
collateral of having that person on is
also me knowing six or seven people
about to get their [ __ ] together
health-wise I get double happy and
that's what I wanted you on the show so
yes I I love when you hop the fence and
like went into a house that hadn't been
touched and there's all sorts of things
but let me give it to you yeah today
give me this first of all because not
everyone's constantly listening and
there may not be the attachment well
introduce yourself tell them what you do
and then maybe go into the first place
you want to go into because we can go to
a lot of places cool uh my name is Mike
chernow I am a born and raised New York
City guy
thought entrepreneurially from a very
young age got into the world of
hospitality and restaurants when I was
young opened up a business called The
Meatball Shop when I was 28 scaled it
sold some Equity launched another
business called Seymour's scaled it sold
some equity and when I was thinking
about my next thing I've kind of got
like a five-year
strategy when I launch a business I kind
of launch it develop value surround
myself with the right people and if it
does what I hope it does I can I can
mitigate some risk is that because
you're so creative and you have a five
bit you're itch and you want to try new
[ __ ] that's because I know what I'm good
at and I know what I'm not good at got
it and if I'm like if I'm if we're five
years in and we're doing somewhere
between 30 and 50 million in Revenue
there is definitely a smarter [ __ ]
person that is going to take that from
50 to 500. you're a zero to Thirty guy
and also you know the truth is is that
like I am I'm a Hunter I am I am I have
a ferocious taste for Discovery I love
lifting up rocks and [ __ ] finding
salamanders with my kids like I could do
that all day that's why you probably
like garage selling that's why I like it
I mean I live when I pull up I'm like
who knows what's here yeah no that's it
that's it you know like I we are on the
hunt for the gray tree Frost legit on
Saturday mornings I'm looking I'm
looking for like a 1940 40s Buck Rogers
rare super ring that was in cereal that
is clearly 10 cents in someone's bucket
that is 48 000 on eBay yeah but I've
been struggling to find that but yes uh
understood okay so yeah so that so
that's where that's where I'm at but but
really the underlying component to my
happiness and success has been my
commitment to Fitness Nutrition and
mindset that has been without a doubt I
decided to change my life 18 years ago I
went from a complete Maniac absolute
addict to this like hard charging head
down Fitness
[ __ ] nut you know and um yeah I mean
every time I see a photo of you on
Instagram I'm like this is a nut I'm a
Nut I mean well I also know you're doing
it the right way so it makes it like
triple weird because there's like nuts
on the talk but I'm like this guy is
injecting all sorts of Wilds like you
really are about that like life well I
think I think for your listener right
yep something that I think is
if there's any value that you get out of
listening to this right now
if you can commit and I know this to be
true because I'm not I'm not a snowflake
I'm no unique dude that just like you
know I I mean I've done things that
would potentially make me unique today
but when I was starting I was saying
snowflake like a unique thing not yeah
yeah someone that's soft right right
snowflake like just want to make sure
there's one store we nailed that
analysis I thought Dustin was confused
in the corner no no like you know
there's not one every single snowflake
is unique I know where you were going
it's that word has been manipulated copy
that yeah just like hustle I have to use
hard work now go figure hard work is
part of the equation go ahead so so you
know when I wanted to when I wanted to
change when I wanted to to actually
change my life I learned that if I could
commit
to taking better care of myself and
truly commit not for the rest of my life
like wake up in the morning and make a
decision to be better to myself every
single day that's that's that is the
trajectory emotionally everything yeah
right because me emotionally is like the
passion of my life like it's very clear
to me if I could just somehow through
another piece of content get people to
like themselves more stop beating
themselves up more but can I share
something about that so so you and I are
very similar there I think that's why we
get along so well is that like this
overwhelming sense of optimism about
life in general right like everybody is
going to deal with pain everybody is
going to deal with challenge everybody
is going to deal with struggle a lot of
it
that person that you're envying or
jealous of right now is dealing with
[ __ ] that you have no idea and every
single person that's made it to the
absolute top
has lost way more than they've won yep
that's that is stats where people miss
it and this is an important Nuance
they've micro lost
not macro logs because people want it so
fast they take these big risks that they
can macro lose but to your point I mean
I lose every day actually me too it's
just a real thing yeah and so I just I I
basically learned early on that if I can
commit to Fitness and Nutrition mindset
stuff came later but if I can commit to
exercise and eating well on a daily
basis and I want to say that clearly
like it's not you know P I think where
people fail in this arena is they say
that's it I'm gonna I'm going to the gym
every day I'm I'm eating brown rice
chicken and broccoli it's too extreme
and it's not sustainable it's not it is
it is sustainable it is from my
experience it is sustainable but the
approach of like I'm gonna go to a place
that's so inconvenient right
it like so inconvenient right and like I
I think people have to find their way
but to your point it's the reason so
many people have a great January and
it's all Fallen apart by April is
because they beat themselves up when
they've had a misstep or two in February
and and the other piece is and so I'll
get to where I'm at now with creatures
of habit but yes we should talk about
crazy yeah
we got a good solid 50. okay I guess 17.
so so that that's my story right the the
foundation the concrete the Bedrock of
my happiness from when I made that
decision when I was 23 years old has
been my commitment to Fitness and
Nutrition now how is that manifested
it's manifested in an amazing marriage
to my wife that we've been married 15
years we'll be together 18 years I mean
it's [ __ ] nuts I feel like a kid and
I've been with this woman for almost 18
years we've got two awesome kids I've
I've launched businesses I've I've had T
you know like I've done a bunch of
things it all started with my commitment
to myself that's the truth and so when I
knew when I was thinking about the next
project what I was going to do real
quick just because I'm thinking about
somebody listening to this I'm like want
them to get value the commitment to
yourself
and you started it with with Fitness was
it I'm an I'm an addict I'm in this bad
place like I need to transform
and this seems achievable and I can
build momentum off of this was it that
logical to win
on a daily basis stacked right so like
it starts with one thing well if I can
if I can exercise and I will also say
another thing
the community of people that you
surround yourself with as you know very
well is going to ultimately have you
sink or swim so are you saying the
people you hung with prior versus the
people you hung with post were very
different makeup very different makeup
and and it's not about yeah yeah it's
not about it's not about Cutting Loose
all your friends it's limiting it's I
keep saying this you don't have to cut
your mom or your best friend out but you
want to be potentially strategic if they
are bringing you down yeah it's not
about completely cutting it loose
tomorrow or today it's about trying to
find one other person to add to add 100
let me give you one because then I want
him to continue that I'm passionate
about on this ad one versus subtract one
the office
like finding one person in the office
that's nice that you like they may be in
accounting they may be like sitting on
the other side of the building like it's
just so in school
like I love what you just said I've not
spoken on this but it's how I think
about it the add one versus the daunting
nature of subtracting one you can start
adding the good while you're still
living in the bad well and by the way
like you start at like one good
will subtract five bad ultimately over
time right especially if you're at wits
end and you're conscious or your
subconscious becoming conscious and you
know you're gravitating towards one good
now I've seen it I I've been that person
for people in school and life so
creatures of habit right that's the new
business creatures with a K uh so just
for the listener to add value for the
kids at home in the back uh creatures
with a K but I wanted I wanted to to be
able to tell that story yeah like that
that is a big that is a big motivator
for me I know money doesn't motivate me
I know creativity motivates me being
able to help somebody motivates me and
being able to tell an experience that
I've had that could potentially
penetrate somebody's life in a positive
way is I think my ultimate thing what is
creatures of habit direct write down the
pipe so everybody creatures of habit is
a lifestyle and wellness brand we we
sell nutritional healthy habits and the
product that we're focused on right now
is this superfood meal oat based you can
make it instant or overnight it's got 30
grams of plant-based protein it's got
omega-3 fatty acids it's got a probiotic
digestive enzymes vitamin D3 chia seeds
flaxseed pumpkin seeds there's six
different flavors you make it like
oatmeal but it's so much more than
oatmeal it is not oatmeal oatmeal is
what we are all used to eating from you
know a pouch of Quaker it is far far
different it is probably just about the
best thing you can put into your body to
kick start your day or post-workout
pre-workout
and for all the DTC people out there
direct to Consumer like real Commerce
people just to nerd up on that part how
do you sell it and what format so we
only sell it to our website right now
yep we're killing it on our website in
what package sizes in boxes of seven so
I could just show you like this is the
product
this is what it looks like for anybody
that's not just listening but for people
that are watching Yep this is the
product that comes in a pouch very easy
to make you could take it with you
anywhere on the go you could I travel
with it I mean I'm I I moved out of the
city so I'm not in the city right now
I you know the truth is I the
interesting thing is is what what it did
for me which is something that I am
incredibly grateful for it brought me
closer to my family of course so I am
like a true Dad I am I am I am coaching
this is I am a real dad coaching the
soccer game on Saturday mornings on the
flip side for you the human being the
electricity that you made I am an
absolute Live Wire in the same person
and it pumps through my blood and so
when I'm here like I got into town on
what's today on Sunday night I drove
into the city I parked my car in the
East Village and I walked five miles
just to be just to like take it in I
have like a meeting in Chicago on
Thursday and I'm like sad that I have to
like be in Chicago like that's how much
more I like New York than every other
place I love it like when I look at like
Philly Chicago Boston like I'm like
these but you want to hear something
really interesting that I noticed on on
Sunday night and also yesterday where
because I'm just like I'm in the city
I'm walking everywhere period I'm just
walking everywhere
I have so much experience in this city
yeah like all over the city yeah and
when I walk through air you know like
how many times do people ask you what
inspires you right like oh what do you
do for inspiration what inspires you and
like the truth is Nostalgia actually
inspires me that's cool to want to do
[ __ ] that's right like if I see a
restaurant that I went to I was I was
walking on Canal Street I passed what is
now I don't remember what I don't
remember what it is now it's like a it's
like a Subway but it was a Blimpie oh
yeah and and my dad and I even though we
had a really tough relationship we would
Bond at Blimpie and so one of the last
meals we had when he was alive was that
Blimpy on Canal Street and I just
stopped there and I was just like wait a
second like it's a spot this is
something to me dude this was it so
anyway so
you combine on our website
um it is
something that you should eat every
single day I eat it every single day
I've been eating it every single day for
years and years the reason why I created
this product is because I was making
this it took me 15 20 minutes every
morning to make I've been doing it for
literally 17 years and then I decided to
put it in a pouch and make it easy for
everybody else what's the biggest thing
you've learned in this first what is it
two what are we two years in uh we're a
year in we just celebrated a year seems
like forever uh learned an enormous
amount what's the biggest surprise Pro
positive surprise uh that I projected
doing a certain amount of money and we
did over 50 better amazing
I found out that we're not oatmeal
and you told me that like day one right
but I was fighting this thing because
because I it was oatmeal for me for
years it was oatmeal for me but I found
out from the community and we've built
this awesome robust amazing Community I
found out from them they're like this
[ __ ] is not oatmeal yeah this is so much
more than oatmeal for us like we take
this wherever we go we never travel with
quick but that's a positive right you
almost just answer me when I'm like
what's your weakness when I interview
people and they're like oh like
sometimes I just work so hard that I
burn out I'm like that's a [ __ ] back
end to compliment to yourself I would
argue that that was a back-end comment
so let me celebrate give me something
more like your first sweatpants sucks
[ __ ] oh got you well that happened I'm
aware that's why I'm bringing it up yeah
yeah honestly because I really do I
think that's I really genuine you only
believe your second thing was you might
have had some slight emotion to it but
the answer is actually a major positive
hence why I was yeah give me something
real for the people out there right now
who had a [ __ ] up shipment and they
don't have the money to replace like for
the [ __ ] people in the trenches yeah
and you're a guy from The Trenches which
do I [ __ ] with you give me something in
year one that was like [ __ ] yeah I'll
tell you A big one so please we we
launched this business in the pandemic
yes we had
you know I'm I am insanely passionate
about apparel apparel is like a big deal
for me I'm very passionate about it and
I didn't want to just take like blanks
and put my logo on it I wanted to
actually do it properly and this was a
mistake
straight up 100 I wanted to design every
piece from the hat to the socks to the
t-shirts to the sweatpants to the
sweatshirt the whole thing everything
I've never designed a piece of clothing
before and so I wanted to do this and I
remember I was on I called I call up G
and I'm like I'm talking to him and it's
I'm like Yo dude [ __ ] I'm like I want I
gotta move you know how many of these
hoodies should I order I'm like I'm
gonna order 150. he's like order 500.
I'm like [ __ ] all right so it just so
happens that
the sleeves were too short
well for me
um you know my I'm I'm on this shorter
end of the scale but the sleeves were
too short and the guys that I was
designing with they weren't they they
were just like yo this is what you want
to do and I was like yeah this is what I
want to do am I doing something wrong
and they didn't say well you need to
extend the sleeves at least an inch
every size up so we we did extend the
sleeves regardless [ __ ] up nightmare
still dealing with it all good we're
also actually we're I'm definitely not
throwing in the towel on apparel because
apparel is a [ __ ] awesome thing for
us to be able to do we got some new
designs in just a little bit more down
the center of the down center lane i i
before I lose you yeah when this
launched off be friends was going crazy
I was so underwater but I wanted to give
love and we did this fun thing together
on Discord tell the story and give me
the follow-up because I've been so busy
even though you know you probably were
laughing like [ __ ] if he's closest to my
business the [ __ ] he doing everywhere
else because I'm so crazy but tell
everybody the story of that what I threw
in at the end yeah and then like what's
what's been happening because I'm
genuinely curious what's been happening
with all the people that signed up for
the subscription slash access okay and
we're gonna do that again in December
January are we yeah hopefully but we're
gonna do it as uh Twitter live I get it
but are you gonna be are we yeah what
you learned
I'll set up to go a little faster like
we were doing a thing for all the be
friends in a Discord Discord yeah right
you you you you connected with your
Discord we did it on Twitter spaces oh
is that true I'm sorry so we're still
Twitter spaces and we were jamming just
talking about the launch of this you
know and then I was like Hey like people
need coaches like access like you're the
Stardust like if people buy right now
for my community can they like get you
and and it was kind of like we didn't
talk about that I just kind of like I'm
gonna I'm gonna tell you what happened
please Barry basically Gary was
basically like for the first hundred
people that subscribe right now chernow
will do a half hour one-on-one with you
and then all of a sudden it was like and
he was like damn he's like holy [ __ ]
he's like trying to how things going I'm
like it's it's awesome and he was like
you know what actually how do you feel
about this Mike anybody who's on this
channel right now anybody who's live if
they subscribe would you take them on as
a one-on-one and legit
276 people in 30 minutes subscribed
which is amazing and we have still a ton
of them if not I think we maybe we lost
20 or 30 percent of them
um but that's nothing that's nothing so
we so so I had my assistant literally
schedule
276 half hour one-on-ones and
it was amazing for me I it was a
blessing in disguise it was a [ __ ] ton
of work
um but it was funny I I call I call up
Gary after I'm like dude 276 he's like
he's like oh no that's only like 47
hours I was like yeah [ __ ]
straight you know I mean it was it but
what I think in that 100 plus hours like
was can you and I was like send an email
and see how many people will do three on
one like but like it was more about like
you're gonna get insights from real
people and I also knew the community
that was listening that day just like
the community that's listening now like
I'm so grateful for like the kindness
and the whole energy of it all I assume
I just want to say [ __ ] out of so you
have you have somebody who who is a
massive fan and her name is Katie um and
if you're listening Katie I just want to
say
Katie texted me a picture of herself
walking
every day and and for me I'm like almost
emotional saying that because we
connected through your yep through that
that experience I told Katie I put a
fitness program I put a nutrition
program together and I said all I want
you to do all I want you to do is commit
to walking every morning that's it I
don't care nothing else nothing else all
I want even if you don't eat the oats
right Dustin liked that one
I saw him you know a little go ahead and
I I want you to I want you to walk and
then I want you to take a selfie and
send it to me how's it going amazing
she's killing it she's killing it she's
absolutely killing it and and you know
I'm sure that I'm sure that there were
more obviously of course my connection
to her meant something
was you know she's a mom she she lives
in Boston she's a heart she's like a
heart wait a minute is she a Patriots
fan
by the way I think I have to I know can
I just say say one thing receipts so I
just want to know is that save your
[ __ ] receipts dude it's so funny that
video went so viral of me reacting to
the Jets Miracle win but what's funny is
99 of the audience had no idea what the
[ __ ] I was talking about
our coach earlier in the week in press
conference the New York media is
impossible they're just beating up the
Jets everyone shits on the Jets and
Coach Salah is why I love the
[ __ ] was like you know what just
so all of you know I'm keeping receipts
I'm keeping the receipts of all of you
that say we suck and we'll never be good
um and I understand that like I love
knowing who's actually doesn't think I
got it like my whole life everybody
thought I was going to lose D's and F's
athletically it wasn't theirs classroom
wasn't there but I was like I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill all you [ __ ] I'm
keeping receipts so I loved it and then
for them to pull off this [ __ ]
miracle nonsensical win I was so hyped
yes I did what I did and I just went
received and nobody even knows what it
means
and like literally everybody in the
office has been asking me like nobody
has a clue what it means except Die Hard
jet bands like who's watching a head
coach's Tuesday press conference if
you're not like you have to be that die
hard of a die-hard of a die hard and so
that's what receipts meant on that Bible
I I was at MetLife on Sunday I watched
the Giants win twice in September I
can't believe the Giants have won twice
in September I'm the happiest person
alive period done and one last thing
before we go if if people are interested
in buying
um they can go online and by using our
website and they can use
kohg
kohgv20 the number 20. 20 off love it so
gb20 your your good businessman you came
up with the code before you got here I
came up with the code literally on the
second right now
Gary I think kohg 20 is good oh for the
20 discount it's gonna be like it's 22.
can we give him a 25 discount
can we I love these people let's do 22.5
that's gonna be no because I just I just
do 22. let's do 22. okay by the way you
want a real insight the reason I didn't
go up to 23 even though I asked for 25
is because I hate Michael [ __ ] Jordan
so much as a Knicks fan that I can't
make it 23 so we're gonna make a double
Deuce so Koh GV 22. Koh GV 22 22 off and
there is a reason why I can't go 25 but
uh respect respect that respect that I
love you you're running a real business
I appreciate you everybody listen go do
the homework go do the homework on this
dude
um I I really think there's something
here for a lot of you and I'm I'm really
excited about us doing something like
that again I really want to understand
how you're thinking about scaling this
because I think that will be valuable
and I appreciate you sharing something
can I just say one last thing before we
go
if you're listening and you're on the
fence about this conversation or you're
just on the fence in general you you
need that one thing to push you over
I don't care if you use this although it
would be awesome if you use this product
all I'm saying to do is commit to one
positive thing every day do it for a
week it's going to feel like a chore
it's real do one positive thing every
day for a week it's going to feel like a
chore once you get through that chore
give it another week so you're in chore
for like 14 days after you get through
14 days of chore and it's little stuff
little push-ups do them lazy because 10
push-ups in the morning I didn't know
how to do them right when me and Mike
first started like it's it's insane what
can actually happen when you put a bled
into every other area of my life so all
I'm saying is commit to one great thing
whether it's whether it's Fitness
whether it's nutrition whether it's
[ __ ] closing your eyes and breathing
for two minutes breathing's big huge
water I think I've drank four glass of
water in my life mistake this [ __ ]
walks around with a tub look at that
[ __ ] you drink the whole [ __ ] no yeah
you do not drink the whole [ __ ] thing
I don't believe I drink I drink one and
a half of these a day but I'm also an
athlete so I I take another level what
athlete dude I'm a [ __ ] athlete man
for what I'm now I'm doing CrossFit but
I'm a pro bodybuilder I am actually a
probe bodybuilder 100 pro card like
bodybuilder yes look it up look it up
100 pro OCB Pro bodybuilder got my Pro
card in November Dustin's an athlete no
I'm serious professional BMX true BMX
I'm an athlete too I'm a Hall of Fame
garage sailor see ya
[Music]